so we have a circle right over here and
the first question we'll ask ourselves
is what are the coordinates of the
center of that circle
well we can eyeball that we can see look
it looks like the center looks like the
circle is centered on that point right
over there and the coordinates of that
point the x coordinate is negative four
and the y coordinate is negative seven
so the center
of that circle would be the point
negative four comma negative seven
now let's say on top of that someone
were to tell us
someone were to tell us that at this
point negative 5 comma negative 9 is
also on the circle
so
negative 5
comma negative 9 on
is on
the circle
so based on this information the
coordinate of the center and a point
that sits on the circle can we figure
out the radius
well the radius is just the distance
between the center of the circle and any
point on the circle in fact one of the
most typical definitions of a circle is
all of the points that are the same
distance or that are the radius away
from
from another point from the sec and that
other point would be the center of the
circle so how do we find out the
distance between
between these two points between
these two points so the length of that
orange line
well we can use the distance formula
which is essentially the pythagorean
theorem
the distance squared so if this is
the length of that is the distance so we
could say the distance squared is going
to be equal to
is going to be equal to
our change in x squared so that right
there is our change in x and not to
write really small but that's our change
in x
our change in x squared
plus our change in y squared
our change in y squared
change in y squared
now what is our change in x
our change in x
and you can even eyeball it here it
looks like it's one but let's verify it
we could view this point as the it
doesn't matter which one you use the
start or the end as long as you're
consistent so let's see if we view this
as this the end we'd say negative 5 it'd
be negative 5
minus negative 4
minus
negative 4 and so this would be equal to
negative 1. so when you go from the
center to this outer point negative 5
comma 9 negative 5 comma negative 9 you
go 1 back in the x direction now the
actual this distance would just be the
absolute value of that but it doesn't
matter that this is a negative because
we're about to square it and so that
negative sign will go away
now what is our change in y
our change in y
well this is the finishing y
negative 9
minus
minus negative 7
minus our initial y
is equal to negative 2. and notice to go
from that point that y to that y we go
to negative 2. so actually we could call
the length of that side as the absolute
value of our change in y
and we could view this as the absolute
value of our change in x and it doesn't
really matter because once we square
them the negatives go away so our
distance squared
our distance squared i really could call
this the radius squared is going to be
equal to our change in x squared well
it's negative 1 squared which is just
going to be 1
plus
our change in y squared negative 2
squared is just positive 4
1 plus 4
and so you have your distance squared
is equal to 5 or that the distance is
equal to the square root of 5. and i
could have just called this variable the
radius so we could say the radius is
equal to
the square root of five and we're done